welcome back everyone las vegas now host
mercedes martinez
with us on this tuesday she's at the mix
94.1 studio
with this new segment we call rise and
shine it's a way to get our days started
on a positive note mercedes good morning
to you
uh last week we saw that adorable video
that little girl
who loves selena and all those other
songs what have you got this morning
well alex this one is really for you
you're going to love it and
any other dog lover out there is going
to want to break out the tissues
watch as this ten-year-old florida boy
is reunited with his dog
two months after it was lost
oh
look at its little leg
[Music]
as you can see the boy just broke
down in tears at the sight of bruiser
now apparently bruiser ran off chasing a
rabbit and the dog
the family couldn't find the dog so they
spread the word out on social media and
they actually got a hold of
animal control and animal services but
they heard nothing so after two months
they basically lost any hope of ever
seeing bruiser again but then
he was picked up as a stray and someone
in animal services thought he looked
familiar
so they started looking on facebook and
lo and behold
it was bruiser they contacted the
parents who then surprised the boy with
his best friend
and the two have been inseparable ever
since alex what do you think are you
crying yes
that's so sweet and bruiser's little
tail and his legs roll up in the air
all happy that is so cute although i
feel like that's how i
am every day with with my dog and that's
what i love about you you lie you could
totally appreciate something like that
any dog lover could it's just such a
beautiful thing to see
yeah a boy and his dog so beautiful and
so hopefully that gets you up and going
today for your rising shine segment
oh i love it yes and gosh after two
months you wouldn't ever expect to see
him again so what a great story
mercedes thank you we love these
segments and it's so good to see you
we'll see you on friday great to see you
too okay bye